[موسيقى]
انا بدي اثر بغض النظر على عمره نشاه
الولد كتير صغير فنحن ما بنشوف تاثيرات
ممكن هاي التاثيرات تكون مختلفه
التاثيرات البعيده المدى هي انه بغض النظر
اذا الولد بيتذكر الحادثه او لا في لها
تاثيرات عليه ممكن نشوفها بعدين بخوف غير
مبرر او بسلوكيات بتظهر بعدين بس احنا مو
بنكون عارفين انه الولد متذكر الحاسه بحد
ذاته بما يخص بوقتها الولد ممكن يكون عم
يبكي كثير ممكن يكون عم بيكون كتير دفاعي
عم يبعد عن الاشخاص ما عم يقدر يروح على
هذا المحل وغيرها من الامور بتدل انه هذا
الولد صاير معه شي وعم يجرب يعطينا اشاره
[موسيقى]
كتير مهم انه الطفل نعطيه الدعم اللي هو
بحاجه له الحلال يلي هو بحاجه له الحب يلي
هو بحاجه له واكيد انه يبعدوا عن اي شخص
سبب له بهذا الاذى لحتى ما يحس هو انه
بعده الخطر موجود وبعده عم بيتعرض لاله
اذا الولد بيحكي بنقدر نتواصل معه كثير
مهم
يلي عمل معه هيك هيدا الشيء غلط ومش مقبول
المؤشرات تختلف حسب العمل اذا عم نحكي
اعمار صغيره فالولد ممكن يكون كتير عم
يبكي لما بناخذه على هذا المكان المعين
لمنقرب من اشخاص ممكن يكون بينقب او بيخاف
لما شخص بقرب عليه حتى نحن كافراد مش مش
ممكن لما نقرب منه ايدنا يمكن يصير في
عنده رده فعل لانه بيخاف انه حدا يلمسه
بطريقه تاذيه